[Music]
everybody remembers abercrombie and
fitch yeah i feel like i'm saying it
like they're not around anymore i don't
even know if they're around gives a [ __ ]
about this i haven't been to a mall in a
long time i think foreigners love them
yeah i always still do huh foreign
asians shopping at abercrombie hollister
oh yeah do they still exist at the mall
i haven't seen them don't even know
that's the darkest [ __ ] in every store
you walk into
the darkest store there's no more
shirtless models though unfortunately
yeah that's that's been done away
there's no point in going anymore yeah
models don't stand there anymore they
don't have that anymore they don't got
the like shirtless dudes in the front
like pillars yeah i know it's gone but
since there's a recent documentary
that's on netflix that's really like
exposing
all the like little races not little but
massive racial things like the um they
had like the whole employee handbook
that described what you should look like
and who they should hire and it's all
like super scandalous we're not gonna
get into that all we're gonna do today
is rate and review some popular
abercrombie shirts of the past yeah so
here's some stuff
they sold a shirt that said do i make
you look fat do i make you look
good
[ __ ] i would rock that now that sounds
like a vegas gift shop shirt dude
i saw that at venice boardwalk dude
that's like 67
yeah right
i want that shirt yeah would you wear it
i'm not even fit i'd freaking rock no
way okay wow i think it's i think it'll
be more funnier if i'm fat boone for
poon how about this will spoon for poon
that's a real shirt that's hilarious
what does that mean though like you're
you're spooning them to get some [ __ ]
yeah all right i didn't know abercrombie
was edgy like that yeah
i didn't know they did fat boy [ __ ] this
wasn't edgy to us back in the day that's
true this was whatever's like we were
like oh that's cool all right
no but i thought their [ __ ] wasn't like
uh like flannels
these are discontinued classic old [ __ ]
shut the [ __ ] up seriously i want these
i thought this was a gag i thought you
were doing steve green bit right now you
really did no this is real [ __ ]
i was like no way they had shirts and
spoons
no way i don't remember any of these
shirts dude i didn't know they were
doing i thought they were doing boring
[ __ ] abercrombie's got to make a
comeback that's why nobody shops there
anymore yeah i didn't even they gotta
bring this [ __ ] back dude i would buy
all this right now this is almost less
gross than the [ __ ] that you do now
here's another classic let's see what
else there is
oh look
gtl you know the deal what does gtl
stand for what do you think
actually i have no idea oh is it jersey
shore's gym tan laundry oh i guess it is
oh damn you're good
gym towel wait jim towel laundry that's
whatever okay oh here's a good one
the island of lesbos every man's dream
i i just really fell in love with the
blank the what the island of lesbos
every man's dream not only is that
entirely inaccurate i can't believe they
actually wrote lesbos on a shirt
i want to meet their design team like
like a group like us hey you don't be
sick an island of lesbos so like one one
key thing to to remember
is that i didn't know they had so much
bro believe this bro and here's here's a
really thing a good thing to keep in
mind did bart write these
prior to influencer marketing prior to
that their uh strategy was to go to the
most popular frats and get them to wear
this stuff so this is who this shit's
made for that would make sense that
would sell yeah i thought it was a
popular kids in high school but that
makes sense because they want the
popular kids in college they went to
like the greek life and they got all the
best like top frets no wonder it looks
bro [ __ ] that's pre-influenced this is
abercrombie okay now we're getting
racial
oh racial racial about this wong
brothers long brothers laundry service
two wong's can make it white
like white like w-h-i-g yeah
wow like make your clothing white yeah
oh that's pretty good something wrong
i actually remember these ones being
like hung on at the store i saw that in
the front window i just remember feeling
so like like like what am i doing in
there in the first place i just remember
going there's nothing i can do about
this [ __ ] like it's so wow so you
remember that he's gotta buy one he's
gotta buy one that's [ __ ] i remember
white dudes wearing this [ __ ]
they were like ah this is so funny
i feel like you would sell that at
spencer's yeah
and yeah right you would think that no
it's literal how about this i need a
girl with a good head on her
shoulders
and it's just i need good head right
yeah you proof i'm into it okay yeah
i didn't know they made it the letters
make it so uh
dude i'd expect this [ __ ] out of swap
meet like i didn't expect this [ __ ] at
abercromber
here's a nice three pack this one says
you blow i'll pop
the middle one says i mow your mom's
lawn that's a good one
favorite
this
and this one is
boss hogg loves cooter what does that
mean i think boss hogg and cooter are
two characters in a show like an old one
cooter means vagina doesn't it yeah now
it does yeah wait cooter was uh dukes a
what's that say that was just a jersey
boy uh jersey boys
this one just says camp beaver tail wow
their branding really changed what does
that mean oh like beaver like that's
[ __ ] yeah yeah why a tail you know
white boys usually say i'ma get some
beaver or whatever here's a nice i've
never heard of that let's go get some
fever
extreme makeover with a paper bag that's
[ __ ] crazy for the needy head damn
company's freaking wild dude loose
cannon right
you're a loose cannon fitch
jesus clearly one of them the other guy
left yeah oh there's more i thought that
was the last one cara oh these ones are
for women by the way
careful i had a
i had a
a bowl of [ __ ] for breakfast
i would love to wear i feel like that's
not offensive today i feel like girls
would rock that i think that's
yeah this one says no money no car no
chance
not lions which girl does buy this where
are your shirts bro that that one is the
abg girl
hold a [ __ ] that's me
she's like maybe i'll wear this on my
[ __ ] period days dude like i don't
know yeah that's crazy interesting right
oh here's two more for women oh wait do
i make you look fat that one oh i didn't
know women blondes are adored brunettes
are ignored
that's old school that's an ultimatum
forever someone blogs are better huh and
oh here we go
who needs brains when you have these oh
that's tint
i don't get
there's no arrows at all so these are
all very real abercrombie fit shirts oh
my god i would like to know which one
sold the most
i don't know they were so gangster back
then i know that asian shirt was so like
i've only been in like um
hollister i've been in abercrombie once
and i just turned around like this ain't
my [ __ ] store man i thought they were
all this i feel like you'll like this
one
i see that you've already met the twins
big fan of that big fan i got a
hollister uh button up i i liked it but
i didn't know it was that kind of store
hollister yeah yeah oh i don't know
about hollister hollister seemed a
little more tame compared isn't it isn't
it the same company yeah but i think
that like it was almost similar like
american eagle abercrombie was first
though a little more like [ __ ]
marketing yeah
i remember back in the day they were
like white people only and then they had
to like start putting black people in
there like people got mad
wow what a great company how do you get
white people only if you open in
montebello though
that's kind of hard
you gotta outsource your white people
that's why they put it there they're
trying to up the white population in
montebello that's how you control the
population not like moving people sewing
yeah witty
t-shirts oh my god sorry we gotta keep
going look at this one
i come in 15 new and exciting positions
is that for men or women damn your
choice
i like that answer they're really
excited free country nick dunn
oh well that's a nice one santa's
disappointed in me oh cause she's
naughty
yeah man so
exactly and that that's a lot of stuff
in that documentary i haven't watched it
yet but um based on the trailer they do
like show the actual like handbook it is
pretty sad man really what does this say
it's just very specific like it'll just
have a like a picture of a black dude
it'll be like dreadlocks are not allowed
just very like straight up in the store
at all you can't if you're working there
yeah she can't wear it no dreadlocks
because i just don't see that as being
like the look
even though that's unnatural hair what
if i'm in the process of getting
dreadlocks
at work
if it's you
you're about to get fired as soon as
that's officially dreaded they're
getting fired i mean they had a specific
target oh they had a super specific they
were looking for the van wilder crowd
yeah for real oh like the jizz not the
legend of
taj that's true that's not that i think
they they put stuff like that to like
say oh you can't have this hairstyle
because they know a certain demographic
has it because instead of saying black
people they're just like uh no reggae
style they eventually did have like
wrapped
they eventually did have like really
good looking black dudes working there
yeah and black women too i remember that
but they didn't they for sure didn't
have asian guys but did they like
whitewash them you know what i mean they
were like we want the wayne brady of
black they had tons of asian girls
working there but the asian men
i don't think got popular until like a
few years ago right yeah you should do
this thanks to dancing they're hot boys
like thanks to me
i think
i think dancers dancers really started
the whole like
um attractive like oh wait i didn't know
they were like asian dudes
i thought they were [ __ ] cooks and
laundry guys like what happened here
definitely did like dance like till this
day like i think it's such a great thing
that that stereotype was added in there
and then k-pop k-pop and then
then like uh mainstream america getting
into like j content
k content like k drama j like
bts yeah but i think i think as a whole
like that entire first gen like that
whole generation of of all of us like
entering entertainment and just trying
to create a different image
yeah to the mainstream but they
completely hijacked that [ __ ] too man
vindi's kind of appropriated the
culture
because there were no there were other
like there were white people and black
like it was literally like 90 something
percent asian that's street racing
[ __ ] import tuner all that [ __ ] was
like 90 something percent asian and
mexican too yeah i was also really proud
that like because it when i was that age
i really believed that like hot like
import models for the hottest girls yeah
and i was like but they're nowhere else
other than here and then when they put
them in like
too fast too furious or fast and beers i
was like finally representation for them
so the world could see like how bomb
these girls abg representation dude
exactly but then it became a fetish well
i mean it also just was phased out i
mean what woman isn't fetishized though
dude like
that's they're all you know the sad
thing is they never got credited for
being legitimate models either so it was
almost like a lower class thing to
represent it was uh for what was like
instagram models right now exactly
exactly model you're an import model
yeah but we still like exalted these
women we're like dude you all are fine
but then still when they entered real
media real media said well those aren't
that's kind of like how they treated the
swimsuit model because they thought the
only type of models were the high
fashion runway or print and it's like
man there's so many different kinds well
you know what's the ironic thing now is
that today
it like that still is true but now you
could be heinously overweight and be a
runway top level model
and you're still above
an import model yeah i know
that's that's a little bit i
don't like it import models still never
got maybe it was because they're
not native and they're imported i think
i think it's also
i don't i don't think anything anything
large nobody likes imports is gonna
support something like import modeling
that they don't have a share in the
success of
they benefit in no way at the success of
like
all of our little sub industries back
then you know yeah can you imagine
america's top import model that would be
sick dave we need to do that dude
who's the tyra who's the tyra banks of
import models oh freaking francine d
francie oh somehow wait she didn't do no
no she was was she porn no she wasn't
she we got to get shanghai lee francine
d sasha singleton sasha singleton
another star even jerry lee because i
think jerry lee is like she's aged um
she's still promoting clubs i think i
think yeah
but she's still like mama lee like she's
still like a community like like fixture
yeah i would love to have something like
that where they could get their shine
because they i would say tilak tequila
but then
she went too alien yeah
she went to like alex jones yeah so i
was like oh she went on reality tv yeah
yeah she had her own show but it wasn't
like for being an informal model it was
just for me but that's how she got her
start yeah but she i think she was the
og in social media like
star she was the first one that popped
like a social media model yeah because
she had the most myspace friends which
is crazy to think
but people still wrote her off and kind
of like laughed at her a little bit too
like they liked her but they were still
making fun of her she just went to the
alex jones part right if she didn't do
that she might have been the asian paris
hilton
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you